TO CALL THE.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER%
THREE MEETING FOR TUESDAY MAY
FIFTEENTH TWO ORDER WERE HALFWAY
THROUGH THE MONTH OF MAY AND.
HEARD THE AYE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE ON ON FRIDAY AND NOW
WE'RE BACK TO.
TALK ABOUT THE A A NUMBER OF
THOSE ITEMS WE BEGIN TODAY WITH
THE.
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
CALTRANS AND THE WE'VE GOT THREE
ISSUES.
TO DISCUSS.
WE'LL BE TAKING NO ACTIONS TODAY.
TAKING NOTE OF THE FACT THAT I
HAVE NO COLLEAGUES HERE JUST
POINT.
BUT WE HAVE NO ACTIONS PLAN
TODAY SO.
WILL BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
AND FOR ALL I KNOW WILL AND IS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. ON BUT THE GOOD
MORNING WELCOME AND THANKS FOR
BEING HERE.
GOOD MORNING I'M LAURIE BERMAN
DIRECTOR CALTRANS EVERY YEAR
CALTRANS PRESENTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ARE CAPITAL OUTLAY
SUPPORT FINANCE LETTER. WHICH
ADDRESSES ARE PROJECT DELIVERY
RESOURCE NEEDS.
FOR THE FOR THE FOLLOWING FISCAL
YEAR IN MAY WE COME BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH ZERO BASED
STAFFING ADJUSTMENTS TO SUPPORT
OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS.
IT'S WORTH NOTING THEN EACH OF
THE LAST TEN YEARS YOU JUST PULL
THE MICROPHONE A LITTLE BIT
CLOSER TO HIM.
IT'S ON RIGHT.
AS FAR AS I KNOW.
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT IN EACH
OF THE LAST TEN YEARS SINCE THE
PEAK OF DELIVERY FOR PROP ONE BE
CALTRANS HAS REQUESTED A
DECREASE IN STAFFING. FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY SUPPORT WE HAVE
OVER THOSE TEN YEARS DECREASE
THE SIZE OF OUR CAPITAL OUTLAY
SUPPORT STAFF BY THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
PROCESS POSITIONS OR ABOUT
TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT.
PASSAGE OF THE LANDMARK SENATE
BILL ONE LEGISLATION PROVIDES A
TREMENDOUS BOOST TO
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND WE ARE
EXCITED ABOUT OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY AND
SUSTAINABILITY OF THE STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
I REQUEST BEFORE YOU TODAY OF
EIGHT HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT POSITIONS WILL
PROVIDE THE STAFFING AND
RESOURCES NECESSARY. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO MEET THE
CHALLENGES OF SENATE BILL ONE.
CALTRANS WILL DELIVER AN
HISTORIC LEVEL OF TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS THAT WILL BENEFIT THE
TRAVELING PUBLIC AND TACKLE A
HUGE BACKLOG OF REHABILITATION
AND PRESERVATION PROJECTS. THAT
HAVE RISEN AS A RESULT OF
DECADES OF UNDERFUNDING. WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE MY KEEPER THE
CALTRANS PROJECT DELIVERY
PROGRAM MANAGER WHO WILL PROVIDE
THE DETAILS OF OUR REQUEST.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR BERMAN AND
HER GOOD MORNING CENTER.
WAS MENTIONED BY DIRECTOR
BERMAN T. CAPITAL OUTLAY SUPPORT
PROGRAM IS PROPOSING TO INCREASE.
BY EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
FULL TIME EQUIVALENTS.
AND TWO HUNDRED AND THREE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE UP
COMING FISCAL YEAR.
THIS IS TO SUPPORT THE DELIVERY
OF THIRTY TWO HUNDRED ACTIVE
PROJECTS WITH OVER FORTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS.
FOR THE STATE HIGHWAY SYSTEM.
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR OUR THREE HUNDRED NINETY
THREE POSITIONS
A PERSON HOW YEARS FOR STATE
STAFF.
FORTY FOUR PERSONAL YOUR
EQUIVALENTS.
OF CASH OVER TIME FOR STATE
STAFF.
AND FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
ARCHITECTURAL AND ENGINEERING OR
ANY CONSULTANT.
THE FDA'S.
THIS REQUEST CONSIDERS OUR
BUDGET YEAR NEEDS WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF A FIVE YEAR WORKLOAD
PROJECTION.
THAT IS INCREASING
TO THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
AVAILABLE FROM S. B. ONE.
RIGHT NOW CALTRANS HAS COMPLETED
THIRTEEN SP ONE PROJECTS.
WE HAVE SIXTY FOUR PROJECTS
UNDER CONSTRUCTION CURRENTLY.
AND MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
BEGINNING THE DESIGN AND FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCE PROCESS
NOW.
THE CDC IS MEETING TOMORROW. AND
WILL ADOPT AN ADDITIONAL TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
SAFETY CONGESTION IN FOR
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM UP PROJECTS.
FOR STATE AND LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
TRADITIONALLY THE COS PROGRAM
COMES TO YOU REQUESTING.
THE BUDGET AT A NINETY TEN RATIO.
NINETY PERCENT FOR OUR STATE
STAFF AND TEN PERCENT.
SINCE.
IN DEVELOPING THIS REQUEST FOR
RESOURCES WE LOOKED AT HOW
QUICKLY WE COULD HIRE.
DROUGHT THE UP COMING FISCAL
YEAR HOW MUCH OVERTIME WE COULD
FEASIBLY YEARS.
AND HOW WE COULD USE ANY
CONSULTANT RESOURCES TO FILL THE
GAPS IN ADDRESSING OUR WORKLOAD
NEEDS FOR THIS NEXT YEAR.
TO ACHIEVE A NINETY TEN RATIO.
FOR THE UPCOMING YEAR WE NEED TO
HIRE ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL STAFF.
BUT WE CAN'T DO THAT BY JULY
FIRST.
OUR PLAN IS TO CONTINUE OUR
EFFORTS TO HIRE AGGRESSIVELY BY
BRINGING ON BOARD AS MANY
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES AS QUICKLY
AS WE CAN.
TO GET TO OUR GOAL OF ACHIEVING
THE TRADITIONAL NINETY PERCENT
STATE STAFF.
TEN PERCENT ANY CONSULTANT STAFF
RATIO.
THE PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THIS REQUEST
INCLUDES A REQUIREMENT FOR US TO
PROVIDE. THE LEGISLATURE MONTHLY
UPDATES ABOUT OUR PROGRESS.
IN MAKING OUR
HIRING GOALS.
IF WE HIRE ABOUT A HUNDRED PER
MONTH.
AND WE CONSIDER ATTRITION.
WE WILL HAVE A NET INCREASE OF
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
THIS NEXT YEAR.
AND WILL REACH OUR GOAL.
OF EIGHT THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE STATE STAFF.
WHICH WOULD ACHIEVE THE NINETY
TEN RATIO.
BEFORE ABLE TO HIRE MORE SOONER
WE WILL.
WERE NOT LOCKED IN BY THE
REQUEST OF THREE HUNDRED NINETY
THREE STATE POSITIONS.
FOUR OF THE PROPOSED PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE.
GIVES US THE FLEXIBILITY WE NEED
AND WILL ALLOW THE PROGRAM TO
ADJUST THE MAX.
OF PERSONAL SERVICES
AND CONSULTANTS
FIT OUR WORKLOAD NEEDS AND THE
ABILITY TO HIRE THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR.
IF OUR PROPOSAL ON THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGES APPROVED
IN FACT THE PERSONAL SERVICES
BUDGET FOR THE OVERTIME AND THE
REGULAR TIME STATE STAFF. MAY
ACTUALLY BE UTILIZED ABOVE THESE
BUDGETED LEVELS
BECAUSE OF THE FLEXIBILITY.
LAST YEAR AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT OUR. LEVEL
OF VACANCIES AT THE END OF THE
FISCAL YEAR AND OUR ABILITY TO
HIGH.
AS WE TRANSITIONED FROM ARE
PROGRAM THAT WHAT IS WAS
DECLINING IN THE COS PROGRAM TO
NOW PERIOD OF GROWTH.
WE'VE HAD AN INCREASED FOCUS ON
HIRING TO KEEP PACE WITH OUR
WORKLOAD PROJECTIONS.
WE ADAPTED RAMPED UP OUR HIRING
PRACTICES OVER THE.
COURSE THIS PAST FISCAL YEAR.
AND WE EXPECT THE HIGHER OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY WE'RE TO
CALTRANS EMPLOYEES THIS YEAR.
AS OF APRIL.
WE HAD ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE VACANCIES.
BUT TWO HUNDRED CONDITIONAL JOB
OFFERS
THAT WERE OUT THERE.
TO ACHIEVE THIS.
EXCESSIVE ARE HIGHER WE
PARTICIPATED IN UNIVERSITY
CAREER FAIRS.
WE'VE MADE FOCUSED EFFORTS FOR
HARD TO.
HIGHER UP HARD TO RECRUIT
CLASSIFICATIONS USING LINK THEN
IN TRADE MAGAZINES.
WE HELD CAREER FAILURE FAIRS AT
MULTIPLE CALTRANS FACILITIES.
WE'VE PERFORMED BASS HIRING
EFFORTS ADS GOING OUT FOR THIRTY
FORTY PEOPLE AT.
FOR.
OUR JOB ANNOUNCEMENTS.
WE'VE TARGETED NATIONWIDE
OUTREACH TO COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES AND PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND WHAT WILL BE WORKING WITH
CALLIE CHAR IN PARTNERSHIP TO
PILOT THE CREW AMBASSADOR CAP
PROGRAM.
TO MEET MOM MORE STRATEGIC OUR
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS.
MOST RECENTLY WE'D GONE TAKING
OUR CALTRANS HER HIRING CENTERS
ON THE ROAD.
SO THIS IS A FULL SERVICE
APPROACH WHERE WE DO BOTH
RECRUITING AND HIRING BY MOVING
ARE HIRING PANELS. AND OUR HR
STAFF TO ARE PERFECT.
TEN CHIU FUTURE EMPLOYEES ARE.
LAST WEEK WE WENT FRESNO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
WITH OUR MOBILE HIRING CENTER.
AND WE HELD INTERVIEWS FOR A DAY
AND A HALF.
THIS RESULTED IN FIFTY JOB
OFFERS.
MADE TALKED MADE QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES THIS IS OUR FIRST
TIRING CENTER.
WE HAVE TWO UPCOMING HIRING
CENTERS NEXT WEEK WILL BE AT
SACRAMENTO STATE TO DO THE SAME
THING.
AND IN EARLY JUNE AT CAL POLY
POMONA.
THIS WILL CONTINUE TO INCREASE
OUR HIRING OPPORTUNITIES
TO TRY TO BRING PEOPLE ON BOARD.
CANDIDATES ARE NOT LIMITED TO
JUST THOSE UNIVERSITIES WERE
USING THESE AS HIRING HUBS SO
WERE ALSO RECRUITING OUT TO THE
NEARBY UNIVERSITIES.
TO LET THEM KNOW THAT WE'RE
HOLDING THESE HIRING CENTERS.
IN HIRING IN THIS WAY WE'RE
GOING TO WEAR THE CANDIDATES ARE
AS OPPOSE ASKING THEM TO COME TO
US AND I THINK WOULD BE SEEN BY
THE SUCCESS THIS PAST WEEK THAT
A SUCCESSFUL.
MOVE TO TRY TO DO THAT.
WITH OUR MORE AGGRESSIVE HARM
APPROACH WE EXPECT TO END THE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FISCAL YEAR
WITH NO VACANCIES.
AND FACT
BUT GOING BEYOND THAT AND
GETTING A HEAD START ON A HIRING
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THE ULTIMATE GOAL FOR CALTRANS.
REMAINS FOR THIS COS PROGRAM TO
MEET OUR OBLIGATIONS AND DELIVER
ARE PROJECTS.
WALT THE SAME TIME ACHIEVING THE
NINETY PERCENT STATE STAFF TEN
PERCENT CONSULTANT FTA MAKEUP BY
THE END OF EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
OR EARLIER.
IN ADDITION THIS REQUEST
INCLUDES NON COS PROGRAM
OPERATING EXPENSES A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION OF ONE POINT TWO
MILLION.
FOR CALTRANS ADMINISTRATION
PROGRAM TO. PAY THE DEPARTMENT
GENERAL REESE HOT SIDE GENERAL
SERVICES.
TO EVALUATE CALTRANS FACILITY-NEEDS IN LIGHT OF THE NEED TO
HIRE MORE STAFF TO DELIVER MORE
PROJECTS.
AND ONE TIME TO MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION FOR THE LEGAL PROGRAM
FOR OUR INCREASED.
.
DESTRUCTION ARBITRATION EXPENSES.
SO IN CONCLUSION WE FEEL THIS IS
THE RIGHT AMOUNT
AND THE RIGHT MIX OF RESOURCES
TO DELIVER NEXT YEAR'S PROJECTS.
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY
AND SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
STATE'S TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
IT ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT TO
AGGRESSIVELY HIGHER WHILE
FILLING THE GAPS UNTIL WE CAN
BRING ON BOARD THIS EIGHT
HUNDRED NEW EMPLOYEES.
TO RECHARGE GOAL EVERY THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE STATE
STAFF.
WHICH AGAIN WILL BE CONSISTENT
WITH THE TRADITIONAL NINETY TEN
SPLIT BETWEEN STATES STEPHANIE
ANY CONSULTANT RESOURCE.
CALTRANS WE HAVE A STRONG
PROJECT DELIVERY RECORD.
DELIVERING NEARLY NINETY NINE
PERCENT OF OUR PROJECTS.
TWO CONSTRUCTION SINCE THE FIVE
SIX FISCAL YEAR. AND WITH THESE
RESOURCES WE INTEND TO CONTINUE
THAT.
STRONG.
RECORD OF UP PROJECT DELIVERY.
THAT CONCLUDES OPENING STATEMENT.
THANK YOU AN WITH RICK SPECTRE
THE A TRADITIONAL NINETY TEN
SPLIT IF I UNDERSTAND IT
CORRECTLY.
.
YOU WERE.
INTENTION IS TO ACHIEVE THAT
SPLIT BUT IT'S GONNA TAKE. A.
A PERIOD OF TIME WHERE YOU DON'T
HAVE.
THE NINETY PERCENT TO OF A
FACTOR.
HOW AND AND THAT'S UNTIL
SOMETIME IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN?
YES SO WE WON'T BE ABLE TO DO IT
IMMEDIATELY WE WON'T BE ABLE TO
BRING A HUNDRED NEW STAFF ON BY
JULY FIRST.
WE'LL DO IT AS QUICKLY AS BE
KEPT THE CAMP AND SOMETIME NEXT
YEAR THANK YOU AND WHAT IS THAT
DUE TO THE SPLIT HOW. FAR OFF OF
THE.
NINETY TEN.
DO ENVISIONED IT TAKING.
OR.
THE BUDGET REQUEST IS OF FOR A
THIRTEEN PERCENT.
EIGHTY SEVEN PERCENT SPLIT
INITIALLY.
AND WE'LL GET TO THE NINETY TEN
SOMETIME IN IN THE FISCAL YEAR.
AND A HOW DO YOU INTEND TO.
FOLLOW.
YOU'RE INTENTION TO GET TO THAT
TO.
HOT NINETY TEN SPLIT.
IN WHAT MECHANISMS ARE IN PLACE
TO TRACK IT.
SO WE'RE WE'RE TRACKING OUR
VACANCIES ARE. ON ON A REGULAR
BASIS AND WE WE GOT OUR REPORTS.
.
WITHIN OUR OUR DISTRICTS AND
WITH ALL OF WITHIN THE PROGRAM.
AND RIGHT NOW THE PLAN IS TO
HIRE A HUNDRED PER MONTH.
WITH ATTRITION THAT WOULD GET US
TO THE EIGHT HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
WITH THE LATEST TOOLS WE HAVE
WITH THE HIRING CENTERS WE
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN WILL WILL BE
AGGRESSIVELY HIGHEST WILL BRING
THE QUALIFIED OUT.
CANDIDATES ON BOARD AS QUICKLY
AS WE CAN AND WE THINK THAT THAT.
WITH THE THE HIRING CENTERS IN
SOME OF THESE OTHER THINGS THAT
I MENTIONED. THAT NAM WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL.
OKAY THANK YOU.
DOES THE LA WILL HAVE COMMENTS.
HOPEFULLY THE SKI WITH THE LA SO.
.
WE THINK THAT IT MAKES SENSE TO
FOCUS ON CONTRACTING OUT FOR NEW
RESOURCES IN THE NEAR TERM AND
WE WOULD SUGGEST EVEN GOING
FURTHER IN THAT DIRECTION THAN
WHAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES.
ARE RATIONALE OF A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THOUGH THE REASON WHY
WE THINK YOU SHOULD FOCUS MORE
ON CONTRACTING OUT IN THE NEAR
TERM. IS THAT.
OUR OFFICES HAD SOME CONCERNS
IN THE PAST ABOUT THE ACCURACY
OF CALTRANS.
CAPITAL THEY SUPPORT STUFFING
REQUEST.
AND SO WE DON'T HAVE FULL M.
CONFIDENCE ARM AND THAT THE
BUDGET DEVELOPMENT METHODOLOGY
THAT THEY USE.
SO I THINK IF YOU APPROVE ON
CONTRACTING RESOURCES IN THE
NEAR TERM AND THEY CAN
DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY'RE FULLY
UTILIZING THEM. THAT IN THE
FUTURE.
YOU COULD CONSIDER CONVERTING
THEM TO US TO PERMANENT NAM
STATE STAFF.
WE KNOW THAT THE COSTS ARE
ROUGHLY THE SAME FOR STATE STAFF
AND CONTRACT STAFF WHEN YOU
FACTOR IN ALL OF THE INDIRECT
COSTS COME FOR STATE STUFF.
AT WESTSIDE TO CONCERNS ABOUT
THE PROM OPERATIONS FUNDING THAT
WAS MENTIONED ON REGARDING THE
ONE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE SPACE STUDY. OUT WE
THINK THAT YOU SHOULD REJECT
THIS PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME AND
BECAUSE A CALTRANS HAD NOT YET
IDENTIFIED THE SCOPE OF THE WORK
WITH DTS.
AND INDEED YES WAS UNABLE TO
PROVIDE OUR OFFICE WITH THE
DETAIL ON HOW THEY ESTIMATED THE
COST FOR THAT STUDY.
AND THEN IN ADDITION.
PART THE REQUEST INCLUDES A
MILLION DOLLARS FOR TRAINING NEW
STAFF THAT'S ONGOING WE THINK IF
YOU DO GO IN THE DIRECTION OF
ADDING NEW STATE STAFF THAT YOU
SHOULD MAKE THAT FUNDING.
LIMITED TERM RATHER THAN I'M
GOING.
THANK YOU I'M WITH RESPECT TO
THAT NINETY TEN SPLIT YOU I
INDICATED THAT YOU BELIEVE THERE
SHOULD BE ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY.
AND MAYBE I MISSED IT BUT CAN
YOU.
.
WHERE DOES JUST?
WHAT THAT MEANS WHO WERE
SUGGESTING TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU HAD NEW COS RESOURCES SERVE
YOU DID WANT TO ADD THE EIGHT
HUNDRED AND AND SEVENTY TWO?
NEW FULL TIME EQUIVALENTS AT
THE MENTION THAT YOU DEDICATE
THOSE FOR CONTRACTING OUT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR RATHER THAN.
STATE STAFF
AND THEN MONITOR TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY'RE FULLY UTILIZING THE
RESOURCES IN THE FUTURE YOU
KHADDAM.
CONVERT THEM TO TO STATE STUFF
AND WE'VE HAD SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT.
.
HOW THEY ESTIMATES STAFFING
NEEDS TO RETHINK SORT OF TAKING
A CAUTIOUS APPROACH A WOULD BE
PRUDENT? SIMILAR TO HOW IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
INSTEAD OF ADDING NEW POSITIONS.
YOU DIRECTED THE DEPARTMENT TO
FILL THEIR VACANCIES WHICH
THEY'VE BEEN DOING HOME.
OKAY THANK YOU ARM AND THE US
DEPARTMENT FINANCE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU A STEEP WALLS HARTMAN
FINANCE
BOB I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT THE
BUDGET AS SET UP PROVIDES THE
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW US
TO. HIRE MORE THAN THE EIGHT
HUNDRED POSITIONS WHICH WOULD AS
IT STANDS ADDING EIGHT HUNDRED
POSITIONS THAT AS OF JULY FIRST
WOULD BE MOSTLY VACANT.
PUTS US IN A SITUATION FOR
BETTER OF OF BEING ABOUT SIXTEEN
PERCENT.
A ANY VERSES FORTIN EIGHTY FOUR
PERCENT STAFF SERVICES AND SO AS
WE FILL THROUGH THE YEAR.
GETS US TO THAT ABOUT NINE POINT
FIVE PERCENT A ANY. AND ODD
NINETY POINT FIVE PERCENT OF
STAFF SERVICES AT THE END OF THE
YEAR SO THAT'S HOW WE GET COME
TO THE THREE PERCENT NUMBER.
BUT THAT IS
MOSTLY BASED ON YOU KNOW WE WE
LOOK AT PROJECTIONS WOULD LOOK
AT HOW WE'VE BEEN DOING WE LOOK
AT.
YOU KNOW NEW METHODOLOGIES TO TO
TRY TO HIRE PEOPLE BUT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT. THAT IT'S AN
ONGOING PROCESS SO.
WE'VE PUT TOGETHER BUDGET THAT
IS OUR BEST ESTIMATE OF WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE BUT ALSO
PROVIDES US THE FLEXIBILITY TO.
IF FOR SOME REASON WERE NOT WE
WE HAVE MORE WORKLOAD IN A
PARTICULAR MONTH OR A PARTICULAR
TIME PERIOD THAN WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO HIRE TO.
WE CAN USE THOSE RESOURCES IN A
NEW CONTRACTING AND IF WE'VE
HIRED MORE RESOURCES THAN WE DID
AND IS THUS WE DON'T NEED AS
MUCH ANY CONTRACTING WE CAN MOVE
THOSE RESOURCES BACK UP SO GIVES
US THAT FLEXIBILITY.
SO FROM THE ADMINISTRATION'S
STANDPOINT WERE NOT AS CONCERNED
ABOUT.
BUT I IT NECESSARILY YOU KNOW
WHO PICKED PICKING UP PICKING A
STARTING POINT AS WE ARE ABOUT.
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THE YEAR. TO COMPLETE THE ENTIRE
PLANNED WORKLOAD WHICH IS THE
THE TOTAL THE TEN THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED NINETEEN.
OF FULL TIME EQUIVALENT WORKLOAD.
IS LONG TO HAVE FLEXIBILITY TO
GET TO THAT NUMBER.
THAT'S NOT A NUMBER THAT'S
NEEDED BASED ON THE BOOK THE
WORK PLANS THAT ARE IN PLACE.
TO COMPLETE ALL THE WORK OF THE
WE NEED TO DO AND FISCAL YEAR
TWO THOUSAND IN NINETEEN.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
IT'S PATTERSON ANY QUESTIONS.
THE MIND CAN.
WHERE'S THE BOARD COULD NINETY.
THE DEFENSE FROM LEGISLATION.
HARTMAN.
THE THE NINETY TEN IT'S JUST
BEEN A SORT OF A LONGTIME
AGREEMENT THAT WE'VE OF SHARED
WITH THE LEDGE OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND AN
ADMINISTRATION IS JUST SORT OF
GONE BY THAT AS A GUIDE.
THERE IS NOTHING THAT WOULD
PREVENT US FROM FIFTY FIFTY.
OTHER THAN THE FACT THAT WE
WOULD THEN HAVE TO I MEAN WEEK
AS WE CURRENTLY STAND WE START
THE YEAR AT IT EIGHTY FOUR
SIXTEEN SO. ANYTHING LESS THAN
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY BE LESS
EMPLOYEES THAN WE CURRENTLY HAVE
COS.
IT ILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END OF ALL OF THE F.
CALTRANS ITEMS COMING UP SHORTLY.
SORRY.
YOU BAKER IS POPPING UP AND DOWN
BACK THERE. YOUR.
WE'LL GIVE YOU A MOMENT DON'T
WORRY.
SO.
PLEASE PROCEED DATA THROUGH
YOUR REMAINING ISSUES.
MORNING STEVEN TECH WITH
CALTRANS.
GOOD MORNING ITEM NUMBER TWO IS
A REQUEST FOR AN EXTENSION OF
APPROPRIATIONS.
FOR THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM.
THIS THAT.
BUT CORPORATION WAS ORIGINALLY
DONE WITH TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FIND. AND THERE WERE
THREE PROJECTS PROGRAM BY THE
CDC TO UTILIZE THESE FUNDS.
THROUGH THOSE PROJECTS ARE
EXPECTED TO RECEIVE AN
ALLOCATION VERY SOON EITHER IN
JUNE OR EARLY IN NEXT FISCAL
YEAR. THERE WERE SOME PROJECT
DELAYS.
WITH THE PROJECT IN SOUTH LAKE
TAHOE DUE TO ENVIRONMENTAL.
ISSUES
THAT HAVE NOW BEEN RESOLVED ARE
IN THE PROCESS OF BEING RESOLVED
AND IN THAT PROJECT SHOULD COME
FORWARD FOR ALLOCATION EARLY
NEXT YEAR. OUT WITH FOR
SUCCESSFUL IN.
EXTENDING MISAPPROPRIATION
THE THIRD PROJECT IS A. RATHER
LARGE PROJECT IN THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY IT'S A BIKE SHARE PROGRAM.
AND THIS PROJECT IS UNDERGOING
DELAYS FOR AN INTERESTING REASON
THEY BIKESHARE INDUSTRIES
UNDERGOING A TECHNOLOGICAL
CHANGE IF YOU WILL.
SO NEW COMPANIES HAVE COME ON
THE SCENE.
A SORT OF DISRUPTING THE OLD
SCHOOL PARADOX BIKESHARE SYSTEM
COVER ABOUT DAKHLA SAYS YEAH NOT
OVERSEEING GUY I THINK HERE IN
SACRAMENTO MANY PLACES IN
EXACTLY THE SAME THING SCOOTERS
ARE. ARE. A I THINK THE MOST
PREVALENT FORM YES I I MYSELF
WOULD TAKE A SCOOTER I'M NOT A
VERY GOOD BICYCLIST.
BUT IN TERMS OF OF THIS PROJECT
IS.
THEY'RE BASICALLY BEING
CHALLENGED BY THE INDUSTRY TO
REEVALUATE THE SCOPE OF THE
PROJECT AND SO.
WHILE THEY'RE DOING THAT WE
NEED THE TIME EXTENSION TO ALLOW
OF. A TIME EXTENSION OF THIS
APPROPRIATION TO ALLOW THIS
PROJECT TO COMPLETE INCOME AND
FOUR OF FOR CONSTRUCTION
ALLOCATION.
IN TERMS OF THE LENGTH OF THE
APPROPRIATION.
THE LANGUAGE OR PUTTING FORWARD
IS CONSISTENT WITH ALL OF THE
OTHER A. T. P. APPROPRIATION.
PERIODS WHERE WE ALLOW A THE
TWO YEARS FOR ALLOCATION BY THE
CDC IN THE ADDITIONAL THREE FOR
INCUMBENTS LIQUIDATION.
AND THAT GIVES US THE THE SAFEST
TIME PERIOD AND IT BRINGS IT IN
LINE WITH.
ALL THE OTHER BUDGET REQUESTS
OF THIS NATURE.
I SAW HOW A IS CALTRANS LOOKING
AT THE ISSUE OF INTER CONNECTED
PRETTY.
BETWEEN BIKESHARE SYSTEM SO HOW
COULD I WE HAVE A UNUSUAL.
SITUATION AND A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WHERE THERE ARE CURRENTLY.
.
TWO BIKESHARE SYSTEMS THAT.
I DON'T TALK TO ONE ANOTHER.
AND YET WE HAVE EIGHTY EIGHT
CITIES MANY OF WHICH BORDER ONE
ANOTHER SO I.
SANTA MONICA LONG BEACH.
UCLA BEVERLY HILLS AND WEST
HOLLYWOOD.
.
BEGIN THEIR PROGRAMS BEFORE.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES BEGAN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND LA
METRO BEGAN THEIR PROGRAM.
AND WE NOW HAVE.
TWO DIFFERENT SYSTEMS
AND. HOT AND IN ONE KIND OF
BIZARRE CIRCUMSTANCE WE HAVE.
I IN THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA.
OF THE.
A CITIES BIKESHARE SYSTEM AND
METRO AT METRO STATIONS TALKING
ABOUT OF PUTTING IN IN THE CITY.
PUTTING AND A DIFFERENT SYSTEM.
BOB WHICH IS JUST KIND OF CRAZY
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
.
NOW EUROPE LAMENTING A SYSTEM IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY HOW IS
THAT CAN INTEGRATE INTO.
WHAT ALREADY EXISTS?
SO THAT'S A VERY DETAILED INDEX
AND QUESTION IT I DON'T
PERSONALLY HAVE THE AS HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON IT FOR AWHILE YOU
MIGHT.
SO I DON'T HAVE PICKING UP
ANOTHER SINCE I.
YEAH I CAN. PROMISE TO GET BACK
TO YOU WITH THE ANSWERS TO THAT
THANK YOU.
AYE IF YOU WOULD AYE.
WASN'T ANTICIPATING ASKING THE
QUESTION IS WHERE WOULD HAVE FOR
TRYING TO GET YOU SOONER BUT
IT'S AN OPPORTUNE TIME I THINK
TO.
HOPEFULLY ADDRESSED THE ISSUE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE REALLY OF
ANY COMMENTS.
I THOUGHT MAYBE HE WITH THE.
LA WE DON'T HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS BUT I
UNDERSTAND USE THAT THE FUNDS
FOR THE. THE THIRD PROJECTS ON
HOLD AND ARE LIKELY TO GET RE
PROGRAM IS PART OF THE NEXT
P. CYCLING TWENTY NINETEEN.
IN LIGHT OF THAT AND GIVEN THE
RECENT INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR
THE DP THREE SB ONE THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WISH TO WEIGH
THE BENEFITS OF ALLOWING THE AYE
ALLOCATED FUNDS INTENDED FOR
THAT PARTICULAR PROJECT TO
REVERT TO THE G. GRF. AFRICAN
OTHER GTF PRIORITIES.
THANK YOU YOU MAY WANT TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT TO A CONNECTIVE
ISSUE ALSO. A.
OKAY SO ISSUE NUMBER TH ISSUE
NUMBER THREE.
THAT'S LISTED ON THE AGENDA
UNDER CALTRANS IS GOING TO. BE
DISCUSSED WHEN WE GET TO THE CTC
THAT RIGHT. WHICH IS.
YES WE'LL DO THAT NEXT THROUGH
WILL.
PFISTER BAKER WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW.
AND OF COURSE ANYONE ELSE WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK ON CALTRANS
ISSUES.
SORRY ABOUT BAKER.
GONNA PUT YOU ON HOLD FOR A
SECOND BECAUSE WE'RE GOOD AT IT
ROLE.
DO YOU USE TO IT. NO WORRIES.
BLOOM HERE FONG.
KALRA MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
ALRIGHT FINALLY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND SORRY ABOUT THAT.
ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT WE WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE SOME COMMENTS ON
THE CAPITAL OUTLAY SUPPORT
ISSUES THIS IS A. VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO US.
AS THE DIRECTOR POINTED OUT
CALTRANS OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
HAS HAD SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS
IN THEIR STAFFING.
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED POSITIONS
OVER TEN YEARS.
AS WE WENT DOWN BY THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED POSITIONS WE DIDN'T
COMPLAIN ABOUT THAT WORKLOAD.
DECREASE WE WENT DOWN AT A RATE
OF NINETY TEN.
NOW THAT THERE ARE SOME NEW
MONEY THE DEPARTMENT IS.
PROPOSING THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED RATIO OF OUT SOURCING.
TO FOURTEEN PERCENT.
THAT WE UNDERSTAND THEY PLAN TO
GET THEIR ON THE LAST DAY OF THE
BUDGET YEAR BUT THAT'S NOT HOW
YOUR BUDGET WORKS. FOR THE
BUDGET WORKS ON AN OVERALL YEAR.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENTS
NUMBERS THEY'RE PROPOSING TO
CONTRACT OUT SEVENTEEN PERCENT
OF THE WORK ON THE FIRST DAY OF
THE YEAR. WE DON'T THINK THAT'S
ACCEPTABLE.
I AGAIN OUR MEMBERS TOLD US THAT
THEY HAVE SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE LA OF
SAYS THEY SAY THEY GOT MORE WORK
THAN THEY KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH.
THEY NEED MORE PEOPLE TO DO THAT
WORK.
ACCORDING TO THE BUDGET
DOCUMENTS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ACOSTA HUNDRED
AND TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS MORE
PER POSITION.
TO OUTSOURCE THAT WORK CAN WE
THINK THAT THAT CAN BE DONE MORE
ECONOMICALLY IF WE STAFF UP. SP
ONE HAS BEEN PASSED FOR A YEAR
NOW THE DEPARTMENTS HAD SOME
TIME TO PUT OF IT GATHER. THAT
STAFFING PLAN WE'VE COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT ON
THE STAFFING PLAN. PEGS PROVIDED
THE DEPARTMENT OF LIST OF A
THOUSAND NAMES OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE READY AND WILLING TO GO TO
WORK AS ENGINEERS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. AND THEY HAVE THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE ON THE HIRING
LIST SO WE THINK THAT THE
DEPARTMENT. A IS CAPABLE OF
STEPPING UP THAT THEY CAN STEP
UP MORE ECONOMICALLY AND SO WE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
YOU JUST THE BUDGET TO MAINTAIN
THE NINETY TEN.
THROUGH THE ENTIRE BUDGET YEAR
NOT JUST ON THE LAST DAY OF THE
BUDGET YEAR THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS
DANIEL LYNCH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CHORUS I WANNA
FIRST STAR BY APPLAUDING IN
THINKING THE DEPARTMENT FOR
THEIR. WORK ON IT INCREASING THE
GOALS OF THE STATE IN BOTH
CREATING ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
ALTERNATIVE TRANSPORTATION
OPPORTUNITIES BUT ESPECIALLY FOR
DELIVERING ON THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AT RISK YOUTH.
AND IN THAT VEIN I WANNA
SUPPORTER ISSUE NUMBER TWO ON
THE ATP PROGRAM IS A VERY NASUS
OR NECESSARY. AND RAPIDLY
GROWING PROGRAM AND WE THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE
TO GIVE THEM THE AUTHORITY AND
THE SUPPORT TO CONTINUE TO.
REFINE AND EXPAND THAT'S
CRITICAL PROGRAM FOR THE STATE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
THIS MORNING.
WILL BE TAKING NO ACTION ON THE
THIS AND ANY. AND AND.
BUT NO ACTION ON THE REST OR
ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA TODAY. I'M THAT
BUT WE WILL NOW TAKE ISSUE WHAT
IS THE AGENDA EYES IS ISSUE
NUMBER THREE BUT CALL THIS HAPPY
FORWARD TO MAKE A PRESENTATION.
ON THAT ISSUE.
AND SINCE THIS IS SIR OUR OUR
REQUEST ORGANIZED GALLIO TWO
PERCENT INTO FIRST PLACE.
SURE GOOD MORNING AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE PROPOSES THAT THE
COMMITTEE ADOPT SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORT PLAYING WHICH WRECKING
THE LA GO TO CONDUCT AN
EVALUATION OF THE PROGRAM THAT
THE ACTOR TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
QUESTIONS FOR CONSIDERATION IN
THE REPORTER IT WEIGHED OUT EACH
AND TO INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE WHAT
TYPES OF PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
FUNDED SINCE THE PROGRAM'S
INCEPTION. WHAT PERCENTAGE OF
FUNDING IS FOR NON
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAMMING SUCH
AS BIKE SAFETY COURSES?
OUR PROJECT SPONSORS HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH IMPLEMENTATION.
AND WHAT PERCENTAGE OF PROJECTS
ARE LOCATED IN WERE DIRECTLY
BENEFIT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
OUR OFFICE CAN WORK WITH STAFF
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO FINALIZE
A REASONABLE TIMELINE FOR
COMPLETION OF THE REPORT.
THANK YOU.
DOES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE
COMMENTS SERVICE WE GO DIRECTLY
TO CTC.
SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S WE SHOULD DO.
I I MATT MITCH WEISS CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THAT
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION I'M HERE AT LAURIE
WATERS WHO RUNS ARE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM. AYE
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE THAT LA O.
COME OUT AND LOOK AT THE PROGRAM
AND AT GIVE US AT ANY INPUT THEY
HAVE ON HOW WE CAN IMPROVE IT.
GREAT THANK YOU.
AND Y'ALL MIGHT WANT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT IN OUR OPERABILITY
ISSUE ON BIKE SHARE THAT.
.
OF THAT I WAS JUST REFERRING TO.
SURE I I THINK IT'S A IT'S IT'S
ONE VERY SIMILAR TO.
WHEN WE FACE WITH THAT TRANSIT
PROGRAMS WHERE EVEN AT SANTA
MONICA THERE ARE THERE MULTIPLE
TRANSIT AGENCIES GOING GOING
THROUGH THERE AND THEY'RE NOT
ALWAYS INTEROPERABLE. I IT IT A
LOT BEEN A PROBLEM FOR DECADES
DEFINITELY AND SO NOW.
A LOT WILL DEPEND ON WHERE THIS
IS AT THIS INDUSTRY IS GOING AS
MISTER TECH MENTION AYE IT'S A.
A IN ITS IN ITS EXPERIENCING A
BIT OF A DISRUPTION
TECHNOLOGICALLY.
AND SO I. YOU KNOW IF THIS
BECOMES MORE LIKE A RENTAL CAR
MODEL THAT. IT'S HARD TO SAY AT
THAT NO RENTAL CARS CLEARLY ARE
NOT INTEROPERABLE SO.
I'M NOT SURE THERE IS A BIT
THERE'D BE A POSSIBILITY THERE
BUT IF WE CAN MAINTAIN IT AS
MORE OF OUR. TRANSIT MODEL THAN
THERE CERTAINLY COULD BE A
POSSIBILITY.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE ON THIS
ITEM.
DANIELLE INCH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS AS I WANT
REPEAT MY COMMENTS PREVIOUSLY
ABOUT JUST KIND OF REITERATE
THAT.
AND OFFER MY SUPPORT FOR THIS
ITEM THE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS.
NEXT UP IS CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL WE HAVE FOR THE TWO
ISSUES
.
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ASSISTANT CHIEF RICH DESMOND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL.
FIRST I WANT TO APOLOGIZE ON
BEHALF OF COMMISSIONER STANLEY.
HE'S REGRET YOU CAN'T BE HERE
IS IN WASHINGTON DC AT THE
NATIONAL PEACE OFFICERS MEMORIAL
ON THE PUBLIC WANT ME TO PASS ON
HIS APOLOGY TO FOR. HIS ABSENCE
OUT WE GET YOU MENTION IT TO ME
ROUTE MAY REVISE ITEMS WOULD
LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER.
THE FIRST IS FOR A WIRELESS IN
CAR CAMERA SYSTEM.
WE'RE REQUESTING FIFTY TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION AND TWELVE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY POSITIONS.
PHASED IN OVER THREE YEARS TO
IMPLEMENT A WIRELESS IN CAR
CAMERA SYSTEM
WITH THE OPTION TO PURCHASE AN
INTEGRATED BODY WORN CAMERA
SYSTEM.
AS WELL AS JUST UNDER FOURTEEN
POINT FOUR MILLION ON GOING UP
BUDGET ONGOING BUDGET
AUGMENTATION FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNT.
EMMA IMPLEMENTATION COSTS AND
POSITIONS WILL BE PHASED IN AS
FOLLOWS.
IN FISCAL YEAR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FOR POSITIONS AND JUST OVER FIVE
MILLION TO WRITE A REQUEST FOR
PROPOSAL CONDUCT PROCUREMENT
CONFIGURE THE SYSTEM AND TEST AT
A FIELD SITE.
IN FISCAL YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY
FIVE POSITIONS AND JUST UNDER
TWENTY THREE MILLION TO ROLL OUT
THIS NEW IN COURT CAMERA SYSTEM
TO FIVE OF OUR NINE FEEL
DIVISIONS.
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE REQUEST THREE POSITIONS AND
TWENTY FOUR AND A HALF MILLION
TO DEPLOY TO THE REMAINING FOR
FEEL DIVISIONS AND THEN FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWO AND ONGOING. A FOURTEEN
POINT FOUR MILLION A BUDGET
AUGMENTATION TO MAINTAIN ASSIST.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE IN IN COARSEST
AND THAT WAS IMPLEMENTED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE THE SYSTEM RELIES
ON THE IS IS ANTIQUATED BECOMING
OBSOLETE. IT RELIES ON HARD
DRIVES IN OUR PATROL VEHICLES
THAT USE DVDS SO WHAT AN OFFICER
US TO DO IS IS IS THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE THE SHIP THAT AS IT'S
RECORDING. INTERACTIONS WITH THE
PUBLIC AT THE END OF THE SHIP
AND OFFER ACCESS TO TRANSFER THE
INFORMATION ON THE HARD DRIVE
ONTO A DVD AND THE BOOK THAT DVD
INTO EVIDENCE IS VERY.
.
IF IT TAKES A LOT OF MANUAL
INTERACTION BY THE OFFICERS FOR
THIS FOR THE SYSTEM.
THE HARBOR IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM
IS FAILING AS YOU CAN TELL JUST
BY THE FACT THAT WERE USING DVD
STILL IT'S AN OLD SYSTEM. AND
THE VENDORS TOLD US THEY WILL NO
LONGER BILL TO SERVICE OR REPAIR
THE EQUIPMENT BEYOND THE END OF
THIS YEAR.
DUE TO LACK OF REPLACEMENT PARTS.
PARTIALLY AS A RESULT OF THESE
FAILURES IN THE LACK OF THE
ABILITY TO REPAIR THEM WE
ESTIMATE THAT IN LESS THAN A
YEAR OVER HALF OF OUR FORTUNE
VEHICLES WILL NOT HAVE ANY
REPORTING CAPABILITY.
WE REALIZE THIS DOES NOT MEET
THE EXPECTATIONS OF OF
POLICYMAKERS CONTEMPORARY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES OR THE
PUBLIC WE SERVE CERTAINLY.
IT'S BECOME WIDELY ACCEPTED FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT ESPECIALLY IN
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE RECORDING
SYSTEMS THAT DOCKING
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN THE POLICE
AND THE PUBLIC TO IMPROVE.
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY
EVIDENCE COLLECTION.
WITH THIS NEW SYSTEM WE HOPE TO
HAVE EVERY IN FORTUNE VEHICLE
INCLUDE OUR MOTORCYCLES BECAUSE
WILL BE A MUCH SMALLER SYSTEM.
AND OUR COMMERCIAL FORCE UNITS
EQUIPPED WITH AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING CAPABILITY THAT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER THAN OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM. MORE RELIABLE
AND MUCH MORE EFFICIENT.
ALONG WITH THE REQUEST FOR THE
IN CAR SYSTEM IS A REQUEST TO.
RE APPROPRIATE THE REMAINING
BALANCE OF FUNDS WE RECEIVED IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO CONDUCT A
PILOT PROGRAM TO STUDY BODY WORN
CAMERA BODY OR CAMERAS ARE
OFFICERS. WE COMPLETED THAT
STUDY.
TOWARDS THE END OF LAST YEAR.
ACTUALLY DEPLOYED BODYWORK
CAMERAS IN OUR OAKLAND FIELD
OFFICE AND STOCKTON FIELD OFFICE.
AND IT WAS IT WAS VERY WELL
RECEIVED THE CAMERAS WERE VERY
WELL RECEIVED BY THE PUBLIC
CERTAINLY AND AND BY THE ACTION
THE OFFICERS WEARING THE CAMERAS.
SO WAS VERY POSITIVE HOWEVER
THERE WERE SOME POLICY IN
TECHNOLOGY ISSUES THAT WE STILL
THINK WEEK WE SHOULD BE WORKING
THROUGH AND TO WORK FOR
REQUESTING THE REMAINING THE
REMAINDER OF THOSE FUNDS BE RE
APPROPRIATED SO WE CAN DO ONE
MORE YEAR. OF A PILOT.
THE GOOD NEWS IS IS AT THE END
OF THE ANOTHER YEAR WE WILL HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DOWN THE ROAD
ASSUMING YOU APPROVE OUR IN CAR
CAMERA REQUEST WILL ALREADY BE
DOWN THE ROAD WITH DEVELOPING
THIS SYSTEM. WHICH WE WILL.
WE WILL DESIGN TO INCORPORATE A
STATEWIDE BODY WORN CAMERAS
EVENTUALLY AT SOME POINT IN THE
FUTURE SO BE IT AN INTEGRATED
SYSTEM IS WHAT WE WILL BE
PURSUING FOR THE IN CAR CAMERAS.
THE OTHER THE OTHER ITEM I MAY
REVISE ITEM WE HAVE.
THAT WE'RE REQUESTING HIS RE
AUTHORIZATION TO PROCEED WITH
REPLACING OUR TRACY AREA OFFICE
AS A LEASE BILL TO SUIT.
WE MITCHELL RECEIVED APPROVAL
FOR THIS PROJECT AND THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT BUDGET ACT BUT
THE AUTHORITY HAS SINCE EXPIRED.
OUR TREATY OFFICE IN SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY WAS BUILT IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN FOUR LACKS
FACILITY REQUIREMENTS SPACE
INSIDE ME CAPABILITIES THAT THAT
WE REQUIRE TODAY.
ON THE PROJECT WAS DELAYED FOR
SEVERAL REASONS BE ORIGINAL
DEVELOPER AWARDED THE LEASE.
THE UNIT REGIONALES IN TWENTY
ELEVEN AND CONSULTATION WITH DTS
I WAS TERMINATED DUE TO LACK OF
PERFORMANCE AND THE WE HAD IT AT
TWO ADDITIONAL. DEVELOPERS.
BOTH HAD TO PULL OUT FOR
VARIOUS REASONS WE HAVE NOT HAD
GOOD LUCK WITH THIS PROJECT.
I'M BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS DDS HAD
SELECTED A FOURTH DEVELOPER IS
CONFIDENT OF THE DEVELOPERS
ABILITY TO PERFORM ON THE
CONTRACT.
I MEAN I KNOW DIGESTS IS HERE
FOR THAT ANYTHING TO ADD TO THIS
PROPOSAL.
DID YOU WANT DO THAT NOW FROM
I'M.
FROM DEPARTMENT FINANCED TO
CLOSE OUR BORDERLANDS ART VERY
VERY SORRY SOMEBODY IT'S UP WE
CAN YOU KNOW.
BUT I'M SURE QUITE HOW TO
RESTORE THAT SORT ITEM. MCGRIFF
I WROTE I APOLOGIZE.
BUT.
AND AND SO THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOU CONSIDERING THESE
REQUESTS AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
THINK IT WITH THANK YOU WITH
WITH RESPECT TO THE AND CAR
SYSTEM AT AT.
SOUNDS LIKE GOTTA.
YOUR WAY OUT OF DATE TERMS OF
THE.
.
EQUIPMENT THAT THAT YOU'RE USING.
AND I UNDERSTAND THE EXISTING
MEDIA IS DVD SO DOES THAT MEAN
OR MOVING TO A CLOUD BASED
SYSTEM. AND. AND THAT WOULD BE
WIRELESS HOW DOES THAT.
TRANSMIT TO THE CLOUD.
AND THAT IS IT STORED IN THE
VEHICLE AND THEN TRANSMITTED
WHEN IT.
RETURNS TO THE STATION ARE. AT
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT WHEN IT'S
RICH RELEA.
.
A SYSTEM THAT MOST LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT HAVE
ADOPTED
IN CAR CAMERA SYSTEMS ARE USING
THESE DAYS IT'S ALL DIGITAL AND
IT AUTOMATICALLY UPLOADED WHEN
OFFICER PULLS INTO THE STATION
FOR INSTANCE SO YOU WOULDN'T YOU
WON'T HAVE THE OFFICER HAVE AN
INTERACTIVE THAT. AND JUST DUE
TO THE NATURE OF THE HIGHWAY
PATROL WE'RE SO SPREAD OUT IN
SOME REGIONS OF THE STATE'S. YOU
WE CAN'T STORE THINGS IN THE
CLOUD WE ACTUALLY AFTAB PHYSICAL
SERVERS AND SOME OF OUR OFFICES
SO WE WILL BE A COMBINED SYSTEM
SOME AREAS WILL HAVE SERVERS
BUILT AND WILL BE UPLOADED
RIGHTS OF SERVERS. AND OTHER
OFFICES IT WILL BE A.
CLOUD STORAGE SOLUTION.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE FOR ELLIE
ó COMMENTS ARE GENRE LEVY OUT.
SOME MIGHT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND.
WE DON'T TAKE ISSUE WITH THE
PROPOSAL TO STYLE AND SAW THE
WIRELESS IN CAR CAMERA SYSTEMS
I'M HEROIN AT THAT WHILE THE
INITIAL INCREASE OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET YEAR IS
RELATIVELY MODEST IT THIS DOES
COMMIT THE STATE. TO SPENDING
FOURTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR FROM THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT. IN THE OUT
YEARS.
AND AND BASED ON THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS PROJECTIONS THAT
THE MOTOR VEHICLE CAN'T RESERVE
WILL DROP BELOW FIVE PERCENT OF
TOTAL IN THE EXPENDITURES IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE. SO WE'D RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE WAY APPROVAL OF
THIS PROPOSAL AGAINST OTHER IN
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT SPENDING
PRIORITIES
I'M AND THE NEED TO MAINTAIN A
POTENT RESERVE IN THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT. WE DON'T HAVE
ISSUES TO RAISE WITH ANY OF THE
OTHER PROPOSALS THAT WE JUST
WENT HOME.
DOES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE
FLORA.
SOME COMMENTS ARE SPECIFIC TO
THAT ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO THE.
MOTOR VEHICLE COUNT.
WE WERE BRINGING A PATH AN
ONGOING ISSUE.
I'M AN ART DEPARTMENT FINANCE
I'M WE DO PROVIDE.
AT OUT YOUR FUND CONDITION
STATEMENT FOR THE MOTOR VEHICLE
COUNT FOR MVA WHICH IS SOMETHING
WE DON'T DEPLETE DO FOR OTHER
FUNDS. WE ARE AWARE OF.
HOW THIS IMPACTS THE RESERVE
BUT GIVEN THE?
PUBLIC SAFETY IMPACT IN FACT
THAT THE EQUIPMENT IS WEARING
OUT FOUND.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT THAT'S MATHIS TIME AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND
KEEP LEGISLATURE PRICE OF ANY
CHANGES.
AND IN THE.
MBA.
SINGLE OTHER QUESTIONS IS A
PUBLIC COMMENT.
NOT SEEN ANYBODY JUMPED UP SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
NAY AND.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES
.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
SO GOOD MORNING AND GOOD CHAIR
THEM A COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
JEANNE SHIMMER OF THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF VEHICLES.
WITH ME THIS MORNING IS ROBBIE
CROCKETT OUR BUDGET OFFICER THE
DEPARTMENT HAS TO REQUESTED FOR
YOU TODAY. THE FIRST ONE IS THE
E. D. OUT TWENTY FOUR AND YOU
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM ONE TIME
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
THE DEPARTMENT'S REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TO EXTEND THE CONTRACT
FOR IT RESOURCES NEEDED TO
COMPLETE. ENHANCEMENTS PARENTS
GIVING DOCUMENTATION AND TRAIN
OF DB STAFF. AS RELATES TO THE
NEW PROCESSES AND PRODUCTS
DEVELOPED AS PART OF AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE IMPLEMENTATION.
DAVIES PRIOR FUNDING REQUEST
ASSUME IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
ELECTRONIC DEAL ID CARD
APPLICATION AND AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE BY JULY TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
SUBSEQUENT TO LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
REQUESTS A DVD THE SECRETARY
STATE AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY AGREED
TO ACCELERATE THE PROJECT
SCHEDULE AND IMPLEMENT AB FORTY
SIXTY ONE. IN ADVANCE OF THE
JUNE PRIMARY. THIS APRIL DEEM
IMPLEMENTED AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
ONE IN ALL FIELD OFFICES
STATEWIDE. TV ROLE ALSO RODE OUT
THE LET TRONIC DRIVER'S LICENSE
IDENTIFICATION CARD APPLICATION
ON THE TOUCH SCREEN TERMINALS.
AND EIGHTY EIGHT TERMINALS.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE OPT OUT
APPROACH A VOTER REGISTRATION
HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED. FOR
DRIVERS LICENSES ID CARDS
DRIVER'S LICENSE RENEWALS.
AND CHANGE OF ADDRESS
TRANSACTIONS UNDER THIS NEW
PROCESS ELIGIBLE CUSTOMERS WILL
BE AUTOMATICALLY REGISTERED TO
VOTE UNLESS THEY OPT OUT.
STAFF NOTED A QUESTION IN THE
CHEN ON THE NEED FOR THESE
RESOURCES SO THE DEPARTMENT IS
WORKING IN CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
AND THE SECRETARY OF STATE. AT
THE DEPARTMENT HAS PROGRAM
ADDITIONAL FUNCTIONALITY THAT IS
PLANNED TO GO TO THE FINAL
TESTING WITH THE SECRETARY STATE
AND THEN BE IMPLEMENTED SOMETIME
AFTER THE JUNE PRIMARY.
THIS INCLUDES LAUNCHING THE ON
LINE VERSION OF ELECTRONIC
DRIVER'S LICENSE IDENTIFICATION
CARD APPLICATION SO CUSTOMERS
CAN FILL OUT IT FILL IT OUT
BEFORE VISITING A FIELD OFFICE
IN THE COMING OF THEIR HOME WITH
THEIR MOBILE DEVICE.
EXCELLING THE IMPLEMENTATION
SCHEDULE OF AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
ONE FROM JULY TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
APRIL TWENTY EIGHTEEN REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THERE FOR
WHICH PUTS SOME OF THE
ENHANCEMENTS AND KNOWLEDGE
TRANSFERRED TO THE DEPARTMENT TO
THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR.
THIS BUDGET REQUEST LOS ALLOW
FOR THE TRAIN OF DEVIANT PLAYS
THAT NEED TO TAKE PLACE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO MAINTAIN
APPLICATIONS WAS A CONSULTANT
CONTRACTS HAVE ENDED. WILL ALSO
ALLOW FOR THE ENHANCEMENTS TO
FOR THE STREAMLINED LOOK TRYING
TO THE TRUCK DRIVER'S LICENSE
IDENTIFICATION CARD APPLICATION
PROCESS SUCH AS ALLOWING
CUSTOMERS. DILETTANTE REVIEW
INSIDE THE APPLICATIONS IN
OFFICE AND INTEGRATE APPLICATION
A DEVIOUS EXISTING SYSTEM TO
LIMIT TV EMPLOYEES. THE KING OF
DRIVERS LICENSE INFORMATION I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
SING THEN.
PLEASE
SO THIS IS AN OPT OUT WHAT KIND
OF A STRUCTURE RIGHT AND WENT TO
FOLKS CAN FILL OUT AN ELECTRONIC
FORM IN THE FIELD OFFICE BUT HOW
DO YOU DEAL WITH FOLKS THAT
NEVER COME INTO THE OFFICE.
BUT OUR.
YOU KNOW.
DOING THINGS MAILING THINGS AND
REMOTELY I MEAN I'M JUST TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND HOW EXACTLY THIS.
PROCESS.
WORKS SO SOMEBODY'S ON THE.
IN THE DRIVER DATABASE THEIR
AUTOMATICALLY.
REGISTERED TO VOTE UNLESS THEY
OPT OUT SO HOW WOULD SOMEBODY
OPT OUT.
SO THEY WOULD MARK ON THE FORM
THAT THEY AND.
CHOOSE TO OPT OUT ON A HARD FORM.
BUT YES LAW ON THE TOUCH SCREEN
HER TERMINAL ITS ELECTRONIC
APPLICATION AND THE CHECK THE
BOX TO TO OPERA WRITE A CHECK A
BOX TO OPT OUT. SO YOU NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDS THEN.
.
TO.
BETTER MANAGE THIS INTERACTION
WELL WHAT WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
USE THIS YOU HAVE TO COME INTO
THE FIELD OFFICE AND FILL OUT
THE APPLICATION AT OUR TOUCH
PIECE TERMINALS. THEN KANSEN IS
TO MAKE THIS AVAILABLE THROUGH
IF YOU WANT IT AND COMPLETE THE
ELECTRONIC APPLICATION IN THE
COMFORT OF YOUR HOME OR A MOBILE
DEVICE THAT'S THE CONDITION SO
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO BE IN A
FIELD OFFICE YOU CAN BE AT HOME.
INCOMPLETE APPLICATION EMPIRE TO
COME INTO THE OFFICE.
PRIOR TO COMING AND YES.
OKAY.
EUROPE IS A PATTERSON.
JUST CURIOUS SIDE SO.
YOU AUTOMATICALLY REGISTER
PEOPLE TO DEVOTE.
RIGHT.
SO.
WHAT PARTY DO YOU REGISTER THEM?
THE CUSTOMER CHOOSES THEIR
POLITICAL PARTY PREFERENCE.
THAT'S SO THEY HAVE.
CHOICES TO.
SO IS THAT NOT.
ISN'T THAT AND IN A SENSE OPTING
IN.
MAYBE IF IT SO I.
YOU OP DEMAND AUTOMATICALLY BUT
YOU GIVE THEM THE CHOICE.
WITH RESPECT TO WHAT PARTY THEY
VOTE FOR YOU CAN SELECT I
REGISTER THE POLITICAL PARTY
PREFERENCE YOU CHOOSE IF YOU ARE.
DECIDE YOU WANT TO VOTE IF YOU
DECIDE YOU DO NOT WANT TO VOTE.
AND YOU ARE OPTING OUT OF THAT
INFORMATION IS SENT TO THE
SECRETARY STATE AND THE
SECRETARY STATE WILL FOLLOW UP.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU WE HAVE A SECOND
ISSUE.
THE SECOND QUEST IS ESSENTIAL
LIFE BECAUSE BROUGH MANAGEMENT
APPOINTMENT SYSTEM. DEVIOUS YOUR
QUESTION REAPPROPRIATION TO
EXTEND THE LIQUIDATION PERIOD OF
FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION FOR
FISCAL YEAR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
OTHER STAFF NOTING THAT GENDO HE
COULD PROVIDE UP BEYOND THE
IMPLANTATION AS OF THIS WEEK WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED THE U. CUSTOMER
FLOW MANAGEMENT AND APPOINTMENTS
SYSTEM. IN OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
OFFICES WHICH IS ALMOST ALL OF
OFFICES WE HAVE A HUNDRED SEMI
TO FIELD OFFICES.
WE ANTICIPATE ALL THE FIELD
OFFICES BE EMPLOYMENT USING JUNE
YOU SYSTEM IN JUNE. THE MANNER
IS TO RECEIVE THE FINAL PAYMENT
AFTER INSTALLATION OFF FIELD
OFFICES AND IT ARRAF ERROR FREE
PERIOD HAS TRANSPIRED. THIS NOT
OCCURRED THIS FISCAL YEAR'S WE
REQUESTING THAT LIQUIDATION
PERIOD IS EXTENDED TO ENACT THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IF I
UNDERSTAND THIS CORRECTLY.
THE ACTUAL INSTALLATION WILL BE
COMPLETE IN ALL ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO OFFICES BY SOMETIME
IN JUNE BUT THERE'S A THIRTY DAY.
UP PERIOD WITHIN WHICH
SYSTEM MUST OPERATE ERROR
FREQUENT THAT WILL FALL INTO
THAT AND MORE THAN LIKELY IN
JULY IN THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR SO
YOU NEED THAT. GUESTS ADDITIONAL
TIME.
BURGER.
HELLO.
NO COMMENT ON THIS PROPOSAL BUT
IF I MAY MISTER CHARLIE TO
RETURN TO THE PREVIOUS ONE
STOPPER BRIEF COMMENT THERE.
WELL FAR OFFICE SAYS THAT NO
CONCERN TO THE PROJECT ITSELF
AND RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
COMPLETING THAT KNOWLEDGE
TRANSFER IN THOSE FINAL
ENHANCEMENTS.
WE JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT WHILE
THE INITIAL FUNDING WAS EXPECTED
BE SUFFICIENT FOR THIS PROJECT
THE DECISION TO ACCELERATE
CERTAIN ASPECTS OF THE PROJECT
DID COME AT THE EXPENSE OF
REQUIRING ITS ADDITIONAL.
FUNDING IN THE LOGIC MIGHT WISH
TO DISCUSS THE DEPARTMENT HOW
THATDECISION WAS RIGHT THAT
GIVEN ITS BUDGETARY IMPLICATIONS.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
DO YOU WANT TO ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE OF THE TELLY OR JUST
RAISED.
NO COMMENTS
TWENTY THREE PEOPLE.
MELISSA DMV WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS.
THAT PROBABLY CUT WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE PARTNER
TECHNOLOGY AND ADMINISTRATION
AND SECRETARY STATE I'M AS
RELATES THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS PROJECT AND THE ASPECT AND
BENEFITS OF ACTUALLY BRING IT IN
EARLY BEFORE THE JUNE PRIMARY.
AND THAT WAS THAT THE KEY FOCUS
OF OF DOING IT IN EARLY.
ALRIGHT
THANK YOU ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
THERE'S NONE SO THAT JOE WILL.
TAKE US TO OUR NEXT DEPARTMENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH POSITION
MOTO.
AND IT.
WE HAVE OF THE P. YOU SEE NEXT.
ONE ISSUE LIFELINE.
SYSTEMS.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
ELLEN MARATHI WITH THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION.
WITH ME I HAVE JONATHAN
ELECTORATES WHO IS THE MANAGER
FOR THE LIFELINE PROGRAMS AND
ANOTHER AND SEVERAL OTHER
PROGRAMS.
THAT BICU SEE IS.
AND IF. FALL BCP REQUEST OUR OF
FOR ADDITIONAL POSITIONS TO HELP
ADDRESS WORKLOAD INCREASES THAT
HAVE OCCURRED. OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
BOB THE MAY REVISION UPDATES
NOVEMBER ESTIMATE.
THE CURRENT YEAR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE COSTS ARE ESTIMATED.
AT THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT MILLION. THAT'S A DECREASE
FROM THE NOVEMBER ESTIMATE WHICH
WAS PEGGED AT ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED NINETY ONE POINT TWO
MILLION.
FOR THE BUDGET YEAR WERE ARE
PROJECTING A MINOR INCREASE.
.
YEAH TO BE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE MILLION SO THAT IT MAY
REVISION HAS THE CURRENT YEAR
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION WERE PROTECTING
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY NINE MILLION FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR.
AND THIS ALSO IS A DECREASE
FROM THE NOVEMBER ESTIMATE.
FOR STATE OPERATIONS.
WE HAVE DECREASES OUT FOR BOTH
THE CURRENT YEAR IN THE BUDGET
YEAR.
HOWEVER BETWEEN THE CURRENT
YEAR IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
WE ARE PROJECTING AN INCREASE
FROM TWENTY THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION TO THIRTY POINT EIGHT
MILLION MOST OF THAT IS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO.
.
THE.
IN TRANSITION COSTS FOR THE AT
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR.
THANK YOU.
BELIAU.
OR.
THANK YOU MISTER SHARE ROSS
BROWN WITH THE LA THOUGH SO
WE'VE REVIEWED THE.
UPDATED ESTIMATES FOR LIFELINE
PROGRAM WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS ON.
YOU'RE CHEN DIED DOES NOTE SOME
POTENTIAL CONSULTANTS EARNS
ABOUT.
ESTIMATES AND.
IN PREVIOUS YEARS OF
SIGNIFICANT OVER ESTIMATES OF
CASELOAD AND COSTS IN THE
PROGRAM.
WE DO WANT TO NOTE THAT AS
YOU'RE PROBABLY WELL AWARE THIS
PROGRAM HAS SEEN SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES IN RECENT YEARS MOST
NOTABLY THE INCLUSION OF OF
WIRELESS AND SO THAT HAS ADDED.
QUITE A BIT TO THE TO THE
UNCERTAINTY.
THE.
UP YOU SEE ALSO THIS YEAR IN
THIS PART OF THE JANUARY BUDGET.
CHANGE THE METHODOLOGY THAT
THEY'VE BEEN USING FOR
ESTIMATING CASELOAD AND SO WE
THINK THAT.
THAT'S A REASONABLE STEP
FORWARD WERE HAPPY DAY AT WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND OTHERS A
MENTION IN YOUR AGENDA HAVING US
LOOK CLOSE MORE CLOSELY AT THE
ESTIMATES HAPPY TO. TECH
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT BATS.
THERE'S ALSO MENTIONED IN YOUR
AGENDA OF HAVING OUR OFFICE LOOK
MORE CLOSELYAT JUST THE
ENROLLMENT AND RE ENROLLMENT
PROCESS ORE GENERALLY.
ALSO HAPPY DE TO HELP THE
COMMITTEE IN WHATEVER WAY WE CAN.
AND WORK WITH YOUR STAFF AND
BALANCING AND WHAT'S WHAT'S
HELPFUL FOR YOU ALL AS WELL AS A
BALLOT IN JUST OF THE WORKLOAD
THAT OUR OFFICE HAS OVER THE
PHONE SUMMER. THANK YOU AT NOW
AND NOTING THAT OF THERE'S A
RECOMMENDATION FOR SOME
SUPPORTING THIS SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE SHAUNA.
AND CONSULTATION WITH LOW
INCOME ADVOCACY GROUPS AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT TO HER.
THOUGHT HE COULD BE TAKING ON.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COULD
MONNING MEMBERS A MILLION WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THE STAFF COMMENTS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
QUESTIONS FROM DYESS.
SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPENS.
ALONG WITH OUR OTHER ITEMS AND.
THAT TEXAS TO THE HOME STRETCH
WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION AND PIZZA. OF GUTHRIE
ISSUES.
AND ONE PRESENTER.
GOOD MORNING WHEN CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
ENTERTAINING THIS ISSUE THIS
MORNING.
WE'VE THREE ISSUES AS YOU NOTED
BEFORE YOU THE FIRST IS WITH
REGARD TO.
BUT THE ENERGY RESOURCES
PROGRAM ACCOUNT WHICH IS OUR
PRINCIPAL FUNDING ENGINE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION.
AND IT IS IN A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT.
SO WE HAVE PROPOSED SOME.
WAYS TO FIX THAT PROBLEM HOW TO
YOU TODAY I THINK YOUR STAFF DID
A GOOD JOB OF OUTLINING THOSE IN
YOUR AGENDA. A DISCO OVER A
SUMMARIZE THE RECENTLY BUT TO
BACK UP HIS SENSE OF WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS. IN CALIFORNIA WE.
WE LOOK AT THIS IS BEING
VICTIMS OF OUR OWN SUCCESS THE.
PATROL OUR URGES A SMALL CHARGE
ON EACH PERSON'S
A POWER BILL.
AND AS WE'VE DONE REALLY WELL UP
OVER THE LAST YEARS AND CLEAN
ENERGY IN A DEMAND SIDE
MANAGEMENT SO ENERGY EFFICIENCY
REDUCING ENERGY CONSUMPTION AND
THEN BEHIND THE METER ENERGY
CONSUMPTION WERE UP TO NEARLY
SIX.
GIGAWATTS OF BEHIND THE METER.
CHIEFLY ROOFTOP SOLAR THAT'S
BROUGHT DOWN THE OVERALL CHARGES
AND CONSEQUENTLY THIS.
BUT FUND WE ARE IN CALIFORNIA
THE LOWEST PER CAPITA CONSUMER
OF ENERGY IN THE COUNTRY. SO.
THAT'S BEEN THE NATURE OF THE
PROBLEM IN COUPLED WITH THAT IN
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE FLAG
THIS FOR THE LEGISLATURE SEVERAL
YEARS AGO BUT COUPLED WITH THAT
WITH THE PASSAGE OF SB THREE
FIFTY. AND SOME OTHER
LEGISLATION WE'VE GOT IT BUT
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES
PENSION HAVE GONE UP WHILE OUR
REVENUES HAVE HAVE GONE DOWN.
THAT'S WHAT BRINGS US HERE TODAY
WE DID LAST YEAR SLASH FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS FROM OUR BUDGET.
BUT WE'RE DOWN TO WHERE WE NEED
TO MAKE SOME SHIPS IN ORDER TO
ROOM
AND.
REMAIN WHOLE SO THE PROPOSAL DE
CALLS FOR A COUPLE THINGS MAINLY.
REMOVING A SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF
FUNDS THE DEFICIT IS ABOUT
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
SORE PROPOSAL TO MOVE.
.
A NUMBER OF POSITIONS FROM THE
IRP ACCOUNT TO THE COIA COST OF
IMPLEMENTATION ACCOUNT WE WENT
AND IDENTIFIED POSITIONS THAT
ARE CONDUCTOR PERFORMING
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THE COIL ACCOUNT NAMELY
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. AND SO THE PROPOSALS
TO SHIFT A NUMBER OF POSITIONS
THERE UP SECOND WERE PROPOSING
TO CONVERT OTHER POSITIONS FROM
A FUND KNOWN AS THE E. THE
ENERGY FACILITY LICENSE FUND SO
WHEN YOU. ARE A POWER PLANT.
OPERATOR ANYONE ABOUT IT TO
BUILD A POWER PLANT. WE'RE THE
AGENCY THAT PERMITS THOSE.
THOSE THOSE PLANS AND CONDUCTS
OF A YEAR LONG A LICENSING
ANALYSIS ON THAT AND SO WE WOULD
SHIP SOME OF THOSE POSITIONS.
OVER TO THE FUND THAT IS
GENERATED BY THOSE ACTIVITIES
OFF OF THE IRP ACCOUNT AGAIN TO
RELIEVE SOME MORE THE PRESSURE
ON THE ON THE.
PER COUNT AND FINALLY IN THIS
IS NOT SOMETHING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WILL NOTED HERE.
WE PROPOSE THAT STATUTORILY WERE
ALLOWED IN NOVEMBER OF EACH YEAR
TO RAISE THAT SURCHARGE THAT WE
HAVE THE GENERATES THOSE FUNDS.
BUT AND WERE AT THE NEAR THE
CAPS WE CAN RAISE A BY ONE
ADDITIONAL MILL. WHICH IS ABOUT
SEVEN CENTS PER RESIDENTIAL
CONSUMER PER YEAR SUCH A VERY
MODEST INCREASE BUT IT DOES
GENERATE ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR. THAT
WOULD GO INTO THEIR PARK OUT.
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS LA RAIL.
COM YEAH.
THIS PROPOSAL REPRESENTS A SCAN
SIGNIFICANT IN OUR VIEW A
REASONABLE STEP FORWARD IN
ADDRESSING THE.
THE DEFICIT IN THE FUNDS.
WE WE DON'T HAVE ANY INITIAL
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED
CHANGES WE DOLLAR.
IS IT ON AN ANNUAL BASIS GOING
FORWARD AND SO.
IT'S WITHOUT ITS PROJECTED TO
GO INSOLVENT TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE SO THERE'S A THERE
IS SOME MORE TIME TO KIND OF
ADDRESS IT BUT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL LIKELY HAVE TO TAKE SOME
ADDITIONAL ACTIONS. IN THE NEXT
COUPLE YEARS AND THE.
.
PART OF THE.
RESOLUTION HERE IS TAKING FUNDS
FROM THE KOREA COUNTER SHIFTING
BECAUSE OF THE DEMANDS OF THE
QUAKE COUNT. HOW SOLVENT IS THAT
FUND AND?
IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT BUNDIST
GENERATING A SURPLUS.
AGAIN AMENDMENT PARTNER FINANCE
BE UP QUITE A FIND IS OF THE THE
CHARGES THAT GOING TO FIND OUR
REASSESS OUR LOOKED AT EVERY
YEAR BASED ON WHAT THE
APPROPRIATION LEVEL IS AND SO
THOSE THOSE WILL BE ADJUSTED.
BASED ON THE TOTAL PROPOSALS NOT
ONLY THIS ONE BUT I THINK ONCE
THE IMPACT THAT FUND SO THAT IT
WILL MAINTAIN SOLVENCY AND WE
DID HAVE THERE'S A LETTER OF
CONCURRENCE FROM THE TIME AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO THIS PROPOSAL.
PLEASE MISTER PATTERSON SO IT
AND. NUMBER IS DONE TO STAND THE
IT TO THE TO THE ALEJO.
A FUND.
WE'LL GO INSOLVENT BY GET WHAT
TWENTY.
EIGHT.
WHEN YOU SEE TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE THAT'S THE
PROJECTION GIVEN YOU KNOW
THERE'S A VARIETY OF FACTORS
THAT ARE UNCERTAIN THAT'S THE
PRODUCTION THAT WE'VE BEEN GIVEN.
SO THE.
WILL YOU BE COMING BACK TO US
SOON TO RAISE THE CAP ON THE
FIFTH ON THAT.
THE CHARGE RATEPAYERS.
WELL WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH IS
IS IT MY COLLEAGUES TO MY RIGHT
CAN ATTEST. REGULARLY WITH
DIFFERENT FINE IT'S LOOKING AT
OTHER OTHER SOLUTIONS AS I
POINTED OUT IN MY TESTIMONY WE
HAVE REDUCED OUR COSTS WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO THAT.
SO THERE'S A SUITE OF OPTIONS
WERE CONSIDERING AS WE LOOK AT
THIS BUT.
AS AS ALEJO POINTS OUT THERE IS
A OUT HERE DEFICIT.
STRUCTURALLY AND WERE WE'RE
LOOKING AT WAYS TO CLOSE IT
RIGHT THAT I HEARD YOU SAY THAT.
YOU'RE NOW YOU ARE YOU ARE YOU
ARE RAISING THE FEE.
TO ITS CAP SO YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER ROOM.
TO CLOSE THIS DEFICIT UNLESS YOU
CUT.
EXPENDITURES
THAT'S RIGHT.
DO YOU INTEND.
DO YOU INTEND TO COME BACK.
FERRICK FOR IT FOR.
LIFTING THE CAP
I GUESS I SHOULD HAVE QUALIFIED
WHAT I SAID THAT LOWERING
EXPENDITURES IS ONE OPTION
ANOTHER OPTION IS THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL WAYS THAT FUNDS CAN
BE SHIFTED FROM ONE ACCOUNT TO
ANOTHER SO THIS IS ONLY ONE OF.
A DOZEN OR MORE ACCOUNTS THAT WE
HAVE AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION
AND WE PARTIED WOULD DESCRIBE
SOME OF THE SHIPS THIS MORNING
AND THERE ARE OTHERS. SO PART OF
IT COULD BE SHIFTING FUNDS NOT
NECESSARILY.
EITHER REDUCING OR INCREASING
FUNDS TO THE HERBA COUNTED DOES
THE LA JOH.
I THINK THAT THERE'S ENOUGH.
.
AB ABILITY IN IT INTER.
DEPARTMENTAL FUND.
IN INTER ACCOUNT SHIFTING.
IN ORDER LOSE THE GAP BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR.
I MEAN I THINK IT'S THAT'S HARD
TO SAY.
I THINK WE. WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT I THINK
IN THE OUTTA KINDA TRY TO
IDENTIFY WHAT THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE I THINK.
ONE OTHER THING THAT WE ARE
NOTED IN THE ADMINISTRATION PUT
FORWARD OUT A REPORT ON THIS
ISSUE JUST A FEW DAYS AGO. A ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT IS IN THAT
REPORT IS THERE ARE SOME
PROGRAMS LIKE PROP THIRTY NINE
FOR EXAMPLE THAT RECEIVE SOME OF
THE.
BUT FUNDING.
AND STE SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES
RELATED TO THOSE PROGRAMS COULD
BE EXPIRING AND FUTURE YEARS IN
SUCH AN EXTENT THAT OCCURS IN
THAT WOULD FREE UP SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDS SO THERE'S A.
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS OF THAT
MIGHT BE OUT THERE BUT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH DETAIL RIGHT NOW TO KNOW
EXACTLY HOW.
RIGHT THANK YOU FAIRS TO THINK
FURTHER I THINK GO WE ASK FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
ACTUALLY WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT
AT THE END OF ALL THREE ITEMS
THAT WE HAVE TO MORE. OF WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE ON TO THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROJECT PROGRAM YES SIR THIS IS
A REQUEST THROUGH MAY REVISE FOR
AN INCREASE OF ABOUT THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES TO THE. FOOD
PRODUCTION INVESTMENT PROGRAM
THIS BUILDS ON A SIXTY MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT LAST YEAR IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. IN AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE JAN TEN BUDGET
THE GOVERNOR BROWN ISSUED
EARLIER THIS YEAR. OTHER BRINGS
THE TOTAL IF THIS MEASURE WERE
APPROVED TWO HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. WHAT THIS IS
FOR IS FOR OUR FOOD PRODUCTION
INDUSTRY IT'S AN EIGHTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF OF WORKERS? AND
WHAT THIS FUND IS DESIGNED TO DO
IS TO ASSIST THEM IN THE
TRANSITION TO A CLEANER ENERGY
PRODUCTION AT THEIR FACILITIES
TO REMAIN COMPETITIVE WITH.
OTHER STATES AND OTHER COUNTRIES%
THAT ARE DOING SIMILAR
ACTIVITIES THE DEMAND FROM THE
FOLKS WE'VE BEEN MEETING WITHIN
THE INDUSTRY OVER THE LAST.
SEVERAL MONTHS AS WE'VE BUILT
OUR PROPOSAL FOR A. SOLICITATION
THAT'S GONNA GO OUT THIS MONTH
TO INVITE APPLICATIONS FROM THIS
INDUSTRY.
WE'VE LEARNED THAT THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT THEY'VE IDENTIFIED IN
PROJECTS THAT THEY NEED TO DO IT
THEIR FACILITIES TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SO. WE
LOOK AT THIS THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS AS A A GOOD ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT AND AS I SAY WE'RE
GONNA PUT THE SOLICITATION OF
THIS MONTH AND WE KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF FOLKS ARE EAGER TO APPLY
FOR THE FUNDS.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OF
MISTER MALONE SO THE ADDITIONAL
THIRTY FROM GEO FROM JANUARY IS
JUST NEW INFORMATION ABOUT THE
THE DEMAND THAT'S OUT THERE.
THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S REYES
MONITOR OF PROCESS AND WE
STARTED IT WITHOUT A CLEAR
PICTURE OF WHAT THE DEMAND MIGHT
BE BUT AS WE'VE GONE FURTHER
THIS IS WHAT WE'VE LEARNED.
AND CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF TRANSITION NOW
IN THE.
A AG INDUSTRY TO.
A NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND ARE YOU
ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT
TRANSITION THAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW TO BUILD IN.
AT ENERGY EFFICIENCIES WE SURE
HOPE SO.
I THINK YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT IN
AND WHAT WE'VE DONE IS I WON'T
GO INTO TOO MUCH DETAIL GIVEN
TIME CONSTRAINTS BUT WERE
BREAKING UP THE SOLICITATION
INTO TO WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
TEARS THE FIRST IS FAIRLY.
STRAIGHT FORWARD TYPES OF ENERGY
REDUCTION ACTIVITIES AND CLEAN
ENERGY PRODUCTION ACTIVITIES
LIKE SOLAR. THE SECOND IS MUCH
MORE CUTTING EDGE AND SO THE
SECOND TIER WERE GONNA AND AND
THESE ARE LARGER AWARDS OF FOLKS
ARE SUCCESS RENT WE'RE GONNA ASK
FOLKS TO.
PROPOSE.
CUTTING EDGE TECHNOLOGY THAT'S
NOT WIDELY USED IN CALIFORNIA.
IT THE BUT THAT'S BEEN PROVEN
ELSEWHERE TO WORK SO THAT WE CAN
BRING NEW TECHNOLOGIES HERE
TRIMARK KICK THE TIRES SEE IF
THEY WORK HOPEFULLY THEY WOULD
THEN SPREAD TO OTHER.
OTHER PARTS OF THE THE INDUSTRY
IN CALIFORNIA AND SOME EXAMPLES
ARE SOLAR THERMAL MICHAEL GIVE
GRADES FUEL SWITCHING.
THESE TYPES OF ACTIVITIES.
IT'S INTERESTING.
.
SING NO OTHER QUESTIONS ALEJO.
YOU WERE RECOMMENDING THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS PROPOSAL.
FIRST THE ENERGY COMMISSION
ONLY RECENTLY FINALIZED THE
FUNDING GUIDELINES FOR THE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IT WAS ALLOCATED
IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
AND THE INITIAL PROJECT THE
WORDS ARE NOT EXPECTED UNTIL THE
FALL OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN. SO AS A
RESULT THAT MAGNITUDE OF THE
ESTIMATED BENEFITS INCLUDING
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS AND
OTHER LOCAL AIR POLLUTANT
REDUCTIONS FROM THE PROJECT IS
IT'S STILL UNCLEAR AT THIS TIME.
I SECOND IF THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERS THESE PROJECTS A HIGH
PRIORITY THERE'S OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES AVAILABLE NAMELY THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS.
WHICH.
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WOULD PROVIDE THIRTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS AT THIS YEAR TO
THE EXTENT THIS UP PROGRAM IS A
HIGH PRIORITY THE LEGISLATURE.
TO CONSIDER REALLOCATING.
ALLOCATING A GTR UP FUNDS FOR
THIS PROGRAM AND JUST FOR
CONTEXT
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
CAP AND TRADE PLAN THERE'S
ROUGHLY. TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN OVERALL GIGI R. F. OF
FUNDING. FOR.
FOR GREENHOUSE GAS RELATED
ACTIVITIES.
THIS APPROACH WOULD LEAVE
SOMEWHAT LESS FUNDING IF THE
LEGISLATURE WERE TO REALLOCATE
TO THIS PROGRAM WOULD LEAVE
SOMEWHAT LESS FUNDING FOR OTHER
CLIMATE REGULAR RELATED
ACTIVITIES. BUT WOULD FREE UP.
THESE GENERAL FUND DOLLARS PER
THE LEGISLATURE'S HIGHS
PRIORITIES.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SOCIETY
ONE OF RESPOND.
TO THE SPECIFIC PROBLEM
CERTAINLY.
.
THIS THERE IS ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND AVAILABLE ON A ONE TIME
BASIS OF WHERE I'M INCREASING
FROM A PROPOSAL OF THIRTY FOUR
MILLION. DID YOUR AFTER A TOTAL
OF SIXTY FOUR MILLION WHICH WILL
KEEP IT IN LINE WITH.
HOW MUCH IS PROVIDE LAST YEAR
THE SIXTY MILLION SO BEAR I'M
CONTINUING THAT MOMENTUM? AMOUNT
FOR THIS FOR THIS PROGRAM AT THE
SAME LEVEL. AND I'M TO DEALERS
COMMENTS IT'S A TRADE OFF NO
MATTER WHAT YOU DO.
IF YOU.
DECIDE NOT TO FIND THIS IS JOHN
FUND AND FUND IT WITH YEAR GIGI
RFU ARE TRADING PRIORITIES
WITHIN THE CONTEXT OF TRAFFIC
CAP AND TRADE THE FUNDS WITH
WITH GENTLE FUN ON A ONE TIME
BASIS AS WE HAVE PROPOSED. YOUR
TRADING PRIORITIES WITH THE
GENERAL FUND SO WE WE THIS IS.
AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM TO CONTINUE
THE MOMENTUM AND KEEP IT THE
SAME LEVELS THAT WAS APPROVED
LAST YEAR THANK YOU ARE WOULD
ONLY A. COMMENT THAT THE.
THERE'S ALREADY.
GHG FUNDING GOTTA I EMBARKED
UNDER THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL IN THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS BEEN.
EXTREMELY RELUCTANT TO UP UP
PART WAS GENERAL FUND MONEY SO.
DEATH SINGLE BUT UNUSUAL.
.
CANADA.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
DYESS.
LET'S MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
THANK YOU THE THIRD ITEM IS.
AS BRIEF IT IS BUT NOT ASKING
FOR FUNDING BUT INSTEAD JUST
AUTHORITY FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO EXPAND
UP TO A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
WE DON'T EXPECT TO BE THAT MUCH.
BUT TO.
DUE TO FUND REIMBURSEMENT FOR
PER DIEM AND ASSOCIATED EXPENSES
FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE
DISADVANTAGED.
COMMUNITIES ADVISORY GROUP THAT
HAS BEEN JOINTLY ESTABLISHED BY
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
AND THE ENERGY COMMISSION. UP
MEMBERS WERE SELECTED AND
ADOPTED BY BOTH BOTH OF OUR
AGENCIES IN THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS THIS OBLIGATION AROSE OUT
OF S. B. THREE FIFTY AS WELL
RESPONSIBLE I'M FOR GOING OUT
HOW TO GET IT RIGHT IN REACHING
OUT TO COMMUNITIES THAT WILL BE
IMPACTED. SO THE GROUP ASSEMBLED
AND THIS AGAIN IS JUST TO
PROVIDE.
INABILITY TO TO REIMBURSE FOLKS
FROM A DIVERSE PART OF OUR PARTS
OF OUR STATE FOR TRAVEL AND A
AND PER DIEM.
ALRIGHT.
ANY QUESTIONS REGARDING THAT
ILIO.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
ISSUES WITH THE PROPOSAL AND
CONCEPTS ARE WE DO NOT THAT THAT
COMMITTEE MIGHT WANT.
ASKS THE ADMINISTRATION TO
DESCRIBE HOW THE BASIS FOR THE
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR CAP.
AT FIRST GLANCE IT SEEMS
RELATIVELY HIGH.
SO THAT COMMITTEE MIGHT WHEN
ASKED THE ADMINISTRATION TO
REPORT ON THAT.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IN RESPONSE TO THAT SIBELIUS
QUESTION COMMENT. IT
IT'S MEANT TO BE A CAP WE DON'T
I GET IT AT THE CAP ACROSS THE
TWO DEPARTMENTS OF EACH
DEPARTMENT MAXIMUM OF FIFTY
THOUSAND AND WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THAT. ONE NIGHT HOTEL STAND TEMP
DISCO IS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS TIMES ELEVEN PEOPLE
MONTHLY MEETINGS YOU KNOW.
WE JUST MIGHT MAKE SURE THERE'S
ENOUGH TO COVER ALL OF THE NEED
TO TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
ADVISORY GROUP.
IS I'M REPRESENTING ALL THE
DIVERSE NEEDS HIM FROM THE ALL
CROSS THE STATE.
THAT'S SERVE HOTEL RATE ON A
GOOD DAY. SEPARATE CISCO.
ALRIGHT TO.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE.
THE.
ENERGY COMMISSION'S THREE
ISSUES.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COTTON GROWERS
IN JENNER'S ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA DAIRIES INCORPORATED
IN THE CALIFORNIA TOMATO GROWERS
ASSOCIATION. ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE AG EFFICIENCY DOLLARS HOW WE
WANNA. SHARKS. AREEXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION FOR BRINGING TOGETHER
THIS GROUP. HOW WE REALIZE IT
FROM THE LEGISLATURE'S
PERSPECTIVE IT'S TAKEN SOME TIME
TO GET THIS DONE BUT I THINK
THEY'RE REALLY DOING THE PROCESS
RIGHT?
AND AS YOU HEARD THE DEMAND IS
OUT THERE. WE NEED TO MAKE THESE
EFFICIENCIES IN THE PROCESSING
ELEMENT OF OUR INDUSTRY TO
SUPPORT THE PRODUCTION AYE
ELEMENT OF OUR INDUSTRY.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT GARY
PROCESSING IN THE NUMBER OF JOBS
IT PROVIDES FOOD PROCESSING THE
NUMBER JOBS IT PERSONAL PROVIDES
WITHOUT THESE ONIES TO ALLOW
THEM TO BE EFFICIENT AND TO MEET
THE S. B. THIRTY TWO GOALS. WE
WILL SEE SIGNIFICANT LINKAGE
WE WILL SEE THESE PLANTS CLOSE
WE WILL SEE THEM LEAVE THE STATE
IF THAT HAPPENS WE LOSE JOBS WE
ALSO CREE SIGNIFICANT HARM FOR
THE PRODUCTION SIDE THE INDUSTRY.
THAT PROVIDES THE CORE A KEY
INGREDIENTS FOR THESE PLANTS SO
WE SUPPORT IT AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
THE MORNING NOELLE CREAMERS
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION I ALSO WANTED TO I'M
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE CAL
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL CALIFORNIA.
I'M.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT WITHOUT
FUNDING TO HELP MAKE SURE THAT
FOLKS CAN BE COMPETITIVE IN
REMAIN COMPETITIVE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH I'M ARE STATES NUMEROUS AT
REGULATIONS AND CLIMATE GOALS.
THAT WE AS MR BROWN STATED WE
WILL SEE ON LEAKAGE AND MOVEMENT
OF THESE FACILITIES TO OTHER
STATES AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE REMAIN COMPETITIVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THESE FUNDS WILL
HELP US DO THAT THANK YOU.
AND MICHAEL BOKURA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA POULTRY
FEDERATION FOSTER FARMS AND. THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
SENSATION ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE PROGRAM. WERE LOOKING
FORWARD TO GETTING THOSE DOLLARS
ON THE STREET THE DEMAND IS
CERTAINLY THERE AND WE HAVE NO
REASON TO BELIEVE THAT THE
BENEFITS ARE NOT GOING TO BE.
EXTREMELY SIGNIFICANT NOT JUST
ON THE GHG SIDE BUT ON THE
CRITERIA POLLUTANT SIDE IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AS WELL THE
PROGRAM IS STRUCTURED.
VERY WELL. I TO PROVIDE THE
BENEFITS TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND TO LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WHICH MANY OF THESE
NAM. PROCESSING PLANTS PROVIDE A
MUCH NEEDED JOBS ONE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY SO IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
pTHAT BRINGS US TO THE END OF OUR
HEARING THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND FOR
EVERYONE WHO. PRESENTED TODAY
AND ADDED COMMENTS.
WE ARE ADJOURNED